[Applause]
oh we got us a jail fine
why isn't he coming in I don't know
maybe he's not buying it hit me harder
[Music]
do I actually have to kill you now we
probably love that but you know I can't
stay mad at you 2016 men this is on you
less than 12 hours later the men escaped
by creating a disturbance in their cell
while they started kissing which I'm
fine with
really I am kiss whoever you want except
they were both men hey sup
pencil-pushers Haverford good to see you
man is it hot in here I feel hot are you
guys hot how you guys doing I'm good you
guys got any snacks Carl is the head of
all outdoor security
why was he transferred from his indoor
desk job you asked listen avatar
I never saw avatar I wanted to read the
book first t-shirt kiss me I'm Irish but
no one would kiss me so you're too
important for me until one of your own
gets attacked I just feel like there's
more we can do to keep the parks safe oh
you think you know how to do my job well
you might not be so confident once
you've walked a mile on my side sevens
kind of small feet actually seven is the
worldwide average boom I don't know was
he I'd rather be back at the office I
know this is painful for you Jerri but
you have to be strong
you guys ready oh boy yeah okay we're
ready I'm going to show you guys all the
problems we've been facing
I'll show you even doing everything we
can I'm looking forward to working
together Carl after that I'm going to
show you this log I found
it's got like 50 worms on it I call it
worm log yeah I've always been a bit of
an outdoorsman when I was a kid my
parents used to make me hang out in the
backyard a lot and just run around till
I got tired but if there's any criminals
out there watching I never get tired and
ladies too thing is a mess we used to
have three carts actually the first one
got pushed into the creek by some kids
the second one raccoons got on two there
was urine everywhere and the third one
was recently stolen what's this one this
is the second one the raccoon piss one
all right so we're gonna just head out
now you know I think we got too much
rain oh that's Tom probably are you
serious Tom can you get off please run
alongside the car okay
okay here we go so tell me a little bit
about the park up here on the left is
one of our most beautiful grass fields
it's primarily grass or I'm gonna make a
hard left here stick with us tom any of
this looking familiar yeah and have him
right over there oh yeah I'm not
surprised take a look at this path with
budget cuts we can't afford a single
safety light there's been tennis alts
already this year
Wow really can't you station a park
ranger out here we have who do you think
they're assaulting I'm sorry I didn't
mean to yell one way or another I'm
gonna get money so you can protect your
and all the other helpless pathetic
people in this town
yes yes slow down no Tom I'm sorry no
can do something's going down it's real
dangerous out here let's roll Carl great
going first I'm afraid you both have the
mumps mumps still a funny word are we
gonna die so you both have the mumps
sorry to say it's very contagious you
may not want to be here detective oh
it's cool I keep up to date on all my
vaccinations I'm immune to stuff you've
never even heard of but not immune to
braggadocio anyhow over the next several
hours you were more than likely
developed fever aching fatigue that
sound too bad
also tart foods will cause intense jaw
pain so you may want to avoid sour
candies what you may get painful greater
like swelling in your neck and often
extreme testicular discomfort okay due
to the highly contagious nature of the
virus you will both be quarantined to
your houses for the next nine days well
nine days in isolation sir I'd be happy
to keep you company we could watch the
10-part Nicholas Nickleby special on PBS
okay there's a lot of long quiet
stretches I do love long quiet stretches
but I don't want to be a burden plus I'm
gonna used to be a male or we could be
quarantined together you know work the
case yes that actually sounds kind of
fun kind of it's gonna be the best week
ever I'm sorry did you not hear me say
extreme testicular discomfort yes we
heard you dr. bad news doctor good
morning everyone
um I'm April Ludgate and I will be
filling in for Leslie while she runs for
office so the new emergency protocol for
the parks department can be found in
your binders what exactly is the chain
of command visa vie on-site response you
know what why don't we just say that
whoever gets to the emergency first will
be in charge okay so if there's an
explosion say in ramsett park and
someone from sewage gets there first
they'd be in charge I had no idea how
terrible Leslie's job is she referred to
this meeting as a non-stop thrill
I'm not quite sure but Tom can answer
that what are you doing it's bouncing
some business ideas off Russell Simmons
on Twitter why all due respect miss
legate do you even know what you're
doing here all due respect mr. hamster
penis but no I don't
my last name is Geils are you sure
because you look like a hamster penis I
knew this moment would come and I will
be the bigger man I'd be happy to help
great we need a doctor here immediately
we have to get your ex-boyfriend I will
not help you
things did not end well between
Frederick and me oh why not
dish service Gina no I can't believe I'm
saying this but we simply don't have
time to hear about the captain's sordid
romantic past what have you become a
hero at a time of crisis you stay here
and take care of Sharon Oh what is she
still pregnant when I get in there then
you'll deal with it sir we're going to
get Frederick right now I'm sure he's
over whatever little fight you guys had
Frederick Happy Thanksgiving
please don't slam the door again we have
a bit of a medical situation I wish I
could help but unfortunately I have a
bit of a wooden duck situation excuse me
right now still all about the duck
Frederick years ago when we moved in
together and antique duck decoy of his
wasn't it placed it wasn't misplaced you
threw it in the trash and with it our
relationship no please we had other
problems or have you forgotten about
Dave
Dave and I were coworkers and nothing
more nothing more right problem solved
everybody's friends let's go help Sharon
I will be happy to assist you if you
will just admit Raymond that you threw
my decoy in the garbage that will never
happen because it's not true thank you
for nothing
good day
hi would you mind just standing there
with your glorious beard for one moment
I'll be right back
what the hell just tell what he wants to
hear but it's a long I don't give a crap
sir
Sharon needs a doctor so get over
yourself and telling you threw away his
stupid duck and give him 20 bucks to buy
a new one
it calls seven hundred and forty dollars
what that is an insane price for a duck
that's way too much all right now I'm
angry about the wrong thing
look just fix this for Sharon
frederik that duck was ugly and gross
and I threw it in the garbage
Wow well I know what I'm thankful for
this Thanksgiving the truth I am so
sorry sir you were a wrong door
you were wrong door hello
hey you're Bianca right mm-hmm I'm Jake
I'm a friend of Freddy's from work I'm
looking for him well which Jake are you
are you jakey lady hands so you jakey
the Jew well it feels weird saying this
but I hope jakey the Jew mm-hmm Jake
Peralta Freddy actually said I should
come by here if I was ever in trouble oh
oh okay
well Freddy was here but he left but
come in Conan Pepe address somewhere
hold on
so did he say where he was heading or
heard about you Peralta I know you were
the rat get him up get your hands up
[Music]
you